in recent years many of us have delved
into our family histories learning more
about those who came before us but few
stories are as compelling as that of
yeshi casa and her great grandfather his
country knew him as royalty thought to
be a descendant of king solomon his
worshipers including reggae legend bob
marley knew him as a messiah and the
world knew him as hala salase ruler of
ethiopia the last in a 3 000 year old
dynasty the new documentary grandpa was
an emperor is all about her journey of
discovery and coming to terms with both
a privileged and very painful
past i was thrilled to be a new yorker
i'm a new yorker
but your heart
my heart heart i'm an ethiopian for 40
years yashi casa has lived in relative
obscurity as a banker in the big apple
exiled from her homeland and her
birthright some people want to call me
princess but i'm really not one
but your grandpa
my grandfather was an emperor yes
grandpa was an emperor is the
little-known story behind the overthrow
of emperor haila selassie
a monarchy which claimed ancestral ties
to king solomon and the queen of sheba
so what do i remember about him he was
very strict
very austere
very quiet you weren't allowed to just
talk and act
in any kind of child-like way you have
to be very grown up
from 1930 to 1974 solasei federalized a
once feudal nation abolishing slavery
resisting italy's fascist occupation
emperor haile selassie rides in majesty
through london and raising ethiopia's
political standing around the world
the white house rolls out the red carpet
for emperor haile celestia he also
presided over the continent's first
african union
but poverty and a crippling famine began
to undermine his rule as well as his
annexation of neighboring
eritrea this is the last picture taken
before our lives went straight to hell
this film answers a lifetime of
questions this was the hardest one ever
because of all these stories filmmaker
constance marks director of sendan's
award winner being elmo befriended casa
while the two volunteered at a homeless
shelter she told me her family's story
and she said we're thinking about either
writing a book or making a film and i
said do you know what i do and she said
no
and i said i'm a documentary filmmaker
casa's story begins in 1973
when at 11 she and her sister were sent
abroad to boarding school
i was badly behaved child so you admit
that freely i do freely admit that um so
they had promised us you know when you
go
you'll be you'll be back in less than a
year
you'll be able to come home
but in september 1974 a marxist leninist
junta called the der sees the nation
my father called and he said
don't come back to ethiopia go to
switzerland
when the revolution first started you
know they kept saying it's going to be a
bloodless revolution
[Applause]
they promised you know
land for the farmers and economic
reforms and political reforms and social
reforms
instead it became a bloodbath first with
the execution of 60 men
then with the red terror which claimed
hundreds of thousands of lives including
that of her father and on august 27 1975
hyla selassie himself
later on discovered that he was murdered
yeah he was murdered
and he used to be an implano
what do you think the perception of your
great-grandfather was versus the reality
i think there was a perception that
he was all-powerful
and i think that's where people make a
mistake about grandpa you know he
abolished slavery he
federalized the system and he had
massive opposition in doing that from
these incredibly
powerful
aristocratic families that had as much
power as her
but it's the survivors that the film
seeks to hail
my mom had resisted
making any kind of firm or talking about
what had happened i was upset that
people did not know what they'd done to
my family and to the women the imperial
women 11 women in her family were held
captive for 15 years was it
worth it being born who we are
absolutely not not for me
i sort of fell in love
with
the fervor by which yes she was telling
her story i call it anta yeshi tony
award winning actress cynthia arrivo is
executive producer aunty yeshi was just
telling this really vulnerable
story
no holds bar we don't get to do that
very often and i just
this
it's a huge huge life that was lived and
is still being lived and i
i just felt immediately like people had
to see it i don't want to spoil it right
i don't want to spoil it but there are
moments there the bob marley moment he
was a good person and he took care of me
the pioneering reggae superstar followed
the rastafarian movement which regarded
selassie as a modern day messiah
marley helped rescue casa's younger
sisters bob was the first person to say
to me like do you actually know
who your grandfather is what he means to
people what he means to the west
what was he to you
he was somebody that i loved very much
casa hopes telling this story will set
the record straight the good and the bad
on all sides
mommy do you think this is important to
do yeah at least they'll have something
to remember because it's it's very
easily forgotten i'm not reasonable
about my family i don't like hearing bad
things about them and it was always this
conversation where people were very pro
the royal family were very against it
and it was hard to get to know the
middle and so this film i think it gave
me real perspective so what do you think
people will say when they see this you
know i think this film is about women
you know
the ladies in london who helped the
princesses who were in prison the the
people who helped rescue my siblings
like this film is about women so i hope
that that's what people see
and this film which isn't it's still
they're still searching for a a
distribution deal
there's so many layers to it i mean one
of the layers she goes back to a
bookstore in addis ababa and she can't
find any
information about her great-grandfather
so it's it's as if the government sought
to erase his whole memory um i have to
give a shout out i know you you said how
did you get this story michelle
um
bill whitaker i have to give one shout
out to bill who saw a screening of it um
and uh dr lupuk's sister corrine lapook
full disclosure she is a producer on
this film they got to get distribution i
want to see it it's an incredible film
yeah there's still so many layers that
we didn't even hit it was interesting
when her sister said right like if you
could go back would you want this life
you know she's like absolutely not yeah
right now
interesting michelle thank you very much